it's rehearsal time at the pack house
theater in blamin the head of the
theater Knut shekinah's is checking out
a new production a romantic comedy in
addition to the Paco's theater shekinah
also manages a number of other stages my
name is Ricky my name is Knut shakiness
I'm an actor I'm 57 years old and I'm
the director of a number of theaters
including the one we're in now I'm also
a set designer on the side and I direct
from time to time he's been living in
Bremen for more than 20 years
Raymond is the most beautiful city in
Germany that's what's up come on Palooza
but what makes the city so magical for
kucik enos the secret is the high
quality of life here
his first recommendation is st. Peter's
Cathedral it was built more than a
thousand years ago making it the oldest
church in Bremen but like many
cathedrals its facade has changed over
the years it was initially constructed
in the Roman style but the church later
received a gothic facelift the pastor
tells us about the Cathedral but besides
a history lesson Knut shekinah says it's
a great place to take a break whenever
I'm here at this church I like to sit
down and look at this beautiful window
and I start to relax and find a bit of
peace and quiet I leave all my stress at
the door and and after 10 minutes in
here I go back out feeling you just
offended on not semi-nude indeed many
hours not Timmy Newton Philippi Buddha
world
visitors to the cathedral can also take
a guided tour next the pastor shows us
the blamin church mouse during the
Middle Ages it was thought to keep evil
out
even today he says the mouse always
brings a smile to visitors what is our
London here of whites is ovz ambitious
we continue on to the you buzzy stat
district the Spicer 11 used to be an old
storage building but today this
historical monument is home to the
restaurant port shakuni's likes to come
here to meet with colleagues in the
acting business the restaurant is quite
popular with the locals they have the
best fish dishes I also really like the
Italian cuisine there's a buffet lunch
you can choose whatever you feel like
eating I like that whenever I come here
I'm always pleasantly surprised the food
is really fantastic today's menu
includes red mullet filet with black
risotto saffron sauce and asparagus and
pheasant breast with juniper sauce and
mashed potatoes
once we've had our fill it's time to
walk the dog we accompany kucik eNOS and
his Terrier Suzy our route takes us
through hip Kinslow park our guides
third recommendation in Bremen it's a
beautiful stretch of land even if spring
is a bit slow to make an appearance here
of course it's also wonderful to sit in
the parks in very much there are plenty
Perkins who in the open oiland area I
need 15 minutes to get here i recharge
my batteries I jog a bit it's just great
Perkins who used to be a country estate
it got its name from the merchant Johann
hoop ken later on he donated the part of
the city opening up the small oasis for
everyone in Bremen to enjoy